what a special occasion we have here you
have no idea you know what I think that
you should do the introduction because
it would be it wouldn't be right if I
did it well please who are we with we
are with the one the only Steven Rosner
who represents me he is my agent along
with a lot of other Krystal Phil Simms
Boomer Esiason Howie Long Chris
Collinsworth and some others in his past
that we will get Brennaman Brian Griese
Bob Papa exactly yes and you know listen
he's he is my agent that's enough but
I've known him for a while and this is
great I mean even fortunately I have
seven paragraphs here but I really want
to do is like how we you know how like
our phone calls go the same way every
time
I do the same thing it rings and then
you answer the phone and you say what do
you even know it
hello Christopher he goes Christopher
and I go Steven it starts like that
every time that you're part of the
family yes I've learned that if you call
Chris Christopher you're part of the
family yeah but I don't call his father
dad everybody calls now man not me only
people in the family that's the
desperation is weird
I talked to since about the Chris about
this we were out in California I said I
thought about this you're your mom's
sisters call your dad dad and and people
that are the same age as him call him
dad it's weird
Dianna calls her husband daddy yes yes
that's why you're here Steve we need the
information but we appreciate you coming
in going top button swag yeah just in
honor of Chris but that's enough of that
all the time it doesn't look good but
you know I'm an older guy and he's like
a young hipster that's where we're
learning that at NBC - they're coming
around - yeah oh yeah they're cool I
mean this thing ain't getting on button
just get some peer pressure from Steve
Rosner that's not absolutely not so how
long have you guys known each other
uh we just were going over this 21 years
I knew of him for a while I knew the
name I never knew exactly because my mom
always used to go like Oh Phil Oh daddy
Oh daddy you should have that
Stephen Rosner represent you he seems
like he's such a good agent oh really
yes yeah you weren't always Phil's agent
no not throwing his playing days uh I
knew Phil I represented one of the or a
couple of his teammates over the years
and I would get it to events with Phil
and I would meet him then and just a
casual hello and he knew I talked your
ear off no he was kind of like you know
he was a stud then I know you know he
was still playing and he was a Super
Bowl MVP yeah you know I tried to get an
autograph every once in a while you know
to give it to somebody but that's about
it but so yeah and then after he retired
him and my partner Frank Bruno had a
relationship and Phil came to our office
twice for two years in a row so four
times talking about us representing him
and each time he just said you know I'm
just too loyal to the guy I'm with right
now right which I really respected and
then the third year he says well let's
meet and I said well Phil let's do it or
not do it and then you know he came in
and he was ready to go and he actually
made the call from our office to his
former to represent yeah and then the
rest is history
I've lunch as the Phil can be expensive
I was gonna say yeah you know he at
least knew that we knew how to eat right
right though and then and that's really
when I Kris I believe at that time was a
junior in high school yeah obviously
getting all the oculars and and then a
recruiting was you know definitely hot
and heavy a tomboy so you know I went to
a couple high school games remember his
dad was working so he couldn't go I went
once with his brother and once with his
mother right and and then he you know we
all thought he was going to Tennessee
and then somehow he ended up in Texas
maybe we need to go there but and then I
saw him a couple times in Texas yeah I
went down with your mom wants and one
time separated dad from beating some
people up in the parking lot
yeah start there we can't you know I
remember Phil was doing a game in Miami
and um and we got a private plane so
that he could get back and forth he went
sat a team meeting during the door in
the morning and then we went I met him
in Miami and then we flew to to Dallas
for the big 12 championship and
unfortunately Kristen have one of his
better games by the way yeah I always
thought this Chris was on a run yeah if
Chris would have played a little bit
better yeah they would have went to the
Rose Bowl right and I think if he would
have played well there there was a good
shot that he was gonna be the first pick
at address I know that game cost me
millions of dollars it probably cost me
the Heisman that's what people don't
realize it was a year where there was no
clear-cut winner in the Heisman right
and we had won about 10 games in a row
and white uh you know what I think it
was Jason White that year so was this
the game where the Roy Williams
infamously like jumped over this is a
Colorado big 12 championship game when
they became this unbelievable running
football team we had dominated them in
the regular season and as a Steve will
tell you we started that game out
dominating I thought we were really I
thought it was gonna be over no see now
Phil Phil didn't go to a lot of games at
that point because of a CBS commitment
yeah so you know we're in the middle of
the of the old Dallas Cowboys Texas
Stadium yeah and obviously with all the
the Texas fans and you know so and then
when it started to turn a little bit you
know the people around us I could see
looking us a little bit differently you
know some were calling for Applewhite
and yeah right and so it got a little
bit uncomfortable but after the game we
were we were gonna go see Chris and we
had to go through the parking lot he's
so recognizable yeah but you know we had
to get to the car we had to go I think
this may be after we saw a Chris we had
to get to the car so we can get back to
the airport to fly back to Miami so
people could do his game on Sunday I was
gonna get the car you know that body
happened to say something to film and he
turned around and I just had to get in
the middle there or it would have got
real so Phil has always been to me with
Christopher like you know you're gonna
do what you got to do whatever
what what changed in him like I don't
need to know what was said but like cuz
Phil's a big dude did he get out like he
was gonna really throw weight around
absolutely yeah absolutely I mean listen
just think about it I mean it's your kid
yeah yeah it's your last name yeah
they're putting four-letter words in
front of it
yes and you know and you're pissed off
because you just had to sit through what
we just saw right so you know he's only
human
you know but you know there was
definitely a lawsuit waiting to happen
you know so I you know I don't do that
much lifting but I got in front of them
I did not get afraid my time at parisa's
at that point I like how you said oh
yeah I represented some giants you
represented the giant that I'm the most
look first of all let's before we get to
that name who are the other giants I
actually want to hear some of the other
names there well there was some guys who
I represented exclusively and then
because I represented these guys the
other guys would say anything any time
you have something give me a call right
right I was introduced I was in the
business for about six months and I was
doing financial management there was
this guy who who was handling money for
actors and actresses and and found and
just thought that the athlete started to
make real money so while I opened up a
sports division and tried to see if I
could recruit you know players so I can
handle the money sure so at that point I
had just finished my grad work at Wagner
College which I was also too sports
information director at and and this guy
said you know here's a cubicle and
here's a salary and start ringing up you
know players to come in for me to handle
money so I know I was all excited so
what I did is I took went to the NFL
the Mel Kiper of that generation and I
Fred Elstein was the guy's name and and
I was looking up all the top guys and I
I spied this guy by the name of Jamie
Dukes and he was a Center at the Florida
and I knew that he was going to be at
the Walter Camp all-american dinner up
at New Haven Connecticut so I went up
there and somehow him and I hit it off
and he came down he met with the the
financial guy and he says I'm in so I'm
all excited - Skyy a two-time
all-american I said great Maya you got
one in the books
my first client this is gonna be great
draft day he doesn't get drafted okay
so I say wow you know but then he this
is Jamie dukes he signs up as a free
agent and this was a lesson to me is you
know you never know yeah he played 1415
years in the NFL I got two Super Bowl
rings he's in the media now yeah and he
was just a great guy so after that a
friend of mine who was from my hometown
of Bayonne New Jersey was had a ticket
sat at the nets and he says you know
I've become friendly friendly with this
with this football player and he's
looking for somebody to maybe handle his
stuff and do some promotional stuff
which was really my background he said
would you be interested me when he says
yeah he says would you like to know who
it is I said yeah that'd be good too he
said Lawrence Taylor so we went out to
dinner and we went out to the palm in
the city and we sat around the table and
at the end of the conversation I said to
Lawrence listen I've been doing this for
like ten minutes
just give me just give me six months and
he said you got three months and three
months turned into shy of 12 years so
what year was that for Lawrence like he
was already had a year or two in there
yeah I was 1984 1984 yeah he was
unrepresented before that he had some he
had some guy in who's doing his contract
in in Houston Wow
and and then here I came and we opened
up LT enterprises and I started you know
dialy and then the first thing he did he
said I want to have a holiday dinner for
all the linebackers and their wives so I
found a place and he said come on and he
introduced me to Carl banks and then I
representing Carl and Carl you couldn't
I mean couldn't be two opposite human
beings playing the same position
absolutely take me through them you know
you know Laurence never trained or
worked out Carl was always training to
work now Laurence always on just as
ability and his inks things Carl had a
study it a little bit more and then from
a business standpoint Carl's a diet
reserved guy now absolutely mother's
pants out to the club that's correct
but I never had it and now you guys are
too young I never had a weight online at
the China Club when I was right Tyson
you know you all when were in there I
mean it was Monday nights at the China
Club that was the spot the spot it was
on 78th Street and Broadway and you know
Tuesdays were off days so who knows man
and you'd go there Monday night and if
he knows who I represent Ron darling
who's the announcer for the Mets and
Turner and you know he says I can't
believe I met you there cuz I was there
every Monday night the Met team was in
there about living in New York now is
missing out on that era of partying in
New York so yeah it's pretty I don't
know if I've done it all the time I
don't think I'd have it in me to every
Monday night but I think just those
names you said right there yeah but you
know it was just more I mean Lawrence
you know people ask me and I have the
standard line they ask me about Lawrence
Taylor yeah and you know my it's very
simple you'll never hear one bad word
out of my mouth never about Lawrence
Taylor because never heard of that line
9 million times if it wasn't for him if
it wasn't for him I wouldn't have my
career you know I mean I was 26 years
old it it gave me really the
introduction of how to deal with the
media how to think on my feet how to
deal with management I was meeting with
mr. Morrow's 27 28 years old and coach
Parcells it's hilarious just think of
you and Wellington Mara the same I mean
coach Parcells I mean you know what
would he say India Lawrence can't own a
strip club behind
jaian stadium get it and I said he
doesn't only he says Steve he might not
own it but he owns it right so I just
saw our coach Parcells up its our about
two weeks ago and him and I were called
the bench that was at the bench it was
something else later on in the day the
satin dolls maybe as I got older right
okay I don't know I can't remember
either but Chris was there but no I
really never was but it was it was on
the way to giant Stadium you could not
go to Giants Stadium without passing
this the veg coach he does not own it
yeah but that was my line but he does
not own it somebody else owns it and get
all the money for it so you know I you
know I never really represented players
for their contracts I thought my point
of difference was doing first a
financial management but then you know
marketing and sponsorship deals so that
means I could go to elder agents and
work with their clients so that was
because they were getting a cut of your
new deal anyway not necessarily but it
was gonna keep their clients happy
gotcha that day at least had somebody
because most of those agents at that
point we're not they didn't or not set
up to do that but it was my background
yeah they were doing the football coach
correct so so I did do one NFL contract
and it was Lawrence Taylor's last
contract so what you asked for Steve I
will so I walk in there and George young
I'm in the office and Joe chunk comes in
he says okay what do you want
so I said 1993 this I said you just
signed Phil Simms for 2.5 million
dollars I want one more dollar than Phil
Simms and two point five zero zero zero
zero one yes and George says I can't
give me that but I'll give you the same
thing I said okay done
well that negotiation took less than 30
seconds Wow
Phil set in the market that's it what we
got into it is that we deserve to be
paid like Philip that point in his
career but I'm that's hard for me to say
either way
I don't know comment until the time
limit is up but what I did but I did say
hey listen after I agree to I said
however let's talk about some bonuses
and I said I'm sure Phil's got a lot of
them but you know I got my defensive guy
doesn't have it
he says Steve take the money I'll throw
a good couple in there I'll let you know
and that was it and I walked out of the
office and called Lawrence up and I told
him he was the highest-paid in New York
job that's great they all they both
retired at the end of the season I went
out to get one out together the stories
that I've heard from Phil and from Chris
about Lawrence just as a person it's
become so endearing in the way that how
did this person live life like this but
still perform at that level and I've
never really heard anyone say anything
bad about him but you're on this side
where you're kind of want to protect him
right so as all these crazy things are
happening what's it like for you are you
telling Lawrence hey calm down or you
tell or you realize the myung-woo yeah
what was the overall experience we've
told stories I might own dad's told a
few funny stories there's no stories to
be told but I will say this I'm two
months older than the guy right all
right and you know we grew up in kind of
the same era you know and I I think
that's one of the things that he
appreciated that I was open-minded to
some of the things that he was doing not
not drugs or anything like that right
but just how he carried on his life not
to say I was gonna carry on my life like
that but at least to be open-minded and
saying you know you shouldn't do this or
you shouldn't do that you know I'm not
his father I'm its representative and
you know what a lot of young guys
including one Christopher Sims I have to
remind him at times I am NOT his father
I just have to give him my guidance and
my thought and let them make the room -
screech me like a son sometimes though
go hi I don't blame me on my taciturn
first of all I consider a younger
brother okay but with Lawrence you know
sometimes it was try
never yeah and it was sometimes that you
know after a while he he realized that
maybe some of the advice I was given him
was good yeah not all of them but maybe
some of it and two things one is that I
remember is that his wife called me up
one time and saying Steve I just want to
let you know there's a lot of people in
Lawrence's life but I know if he's in a
really bad spot or he needs somebody
you're the first caller right so that
made me feel really good that's kind of
that people have that kind of feeling
that you can get something done in that
you really care about the person so that
was one of the things I mean just off
the cuff that yeah I remember about
those times and I was building a
business you know I was single I was I
was spending all my time on my business
and Lawrence helped me business build it
I mean at one point I had Carl and
Lawrence and some Philadelphia Eagles
that were pretty promise that Joyner and
Clyde Simmons yeah so you're like the
nastiest four dudes and and like
everybody on the team I mean I probably
did like 3040 appearances for my quick
and oh and and and kind of ironic
because of my point of frankly
relationship Randall Cunningham how was
that his wedding and still involved with
him he's a really is the man he's an
interesting guy he had a Denzel Sun and
here is the actor Klansman and he grew
up idolizing yeah I could see that
change yeah but what I did was this
since I had the Philly guys and I had
the New York guys what I did and I saw a
recruit and he said you know I'm a
Jersey guy very rarely am I gonna
connect with a guy from Southern
California I'm just just not gonna do it
as far as it would cost me a lot of
money to recruit them and whatever so
the best business thing so what I did is
I researched the top 20 college football
players that grew up anywhere from South
Jersey to the tip of Connecticut huh and
I went out to there and I recruited them
and
I used the Lorentz tail as the Carl
banks I remember and we laughed together
to this day about this Ricky Proehl
Ricky Proehl father was a giant season
ticket holder it could have been like
the easiest recruit of all time I met
him at the blue-gray game he went to
Wake Forest he came up to New York
Lawrence had just opened his restaurant
we went to there and then Lawrence came
over and said hello two minutes later
Ricky was always Ricky Proehl ki Simms
who was from Jersey who played with the
dolphins Eric Williams who later play
for the Dallas he grew up in
Philadelphia you went to Central Ohio it
was cool it's kids Scott Conover he went
to Purdue play for Detroit so at one
point I was you know I was just being
smart about it you know just recruiting
guys that they said Oh Lawrence Taylor
and Carl banks or Seth Joyner and you
know says from Rockland County so you
know I would you know go over and see a
couple it's funny to me that you could
sit there with like a piece of paper and
you're like looking at the Jersey guys
in New York guys that's how open it was
now it's like they're trying to sign
kids at seventh grade yeah but you want
to know something the other thing is is
that you know just like anything else
you got to have a plan it's nothing like
that's his line isn't it you gotta have
a five definitely the Stephen hey it's
work it's worked 100 that's what I tell
young people suffer there's a plan a and
a plan B always alright so I go you'll
need to give me a story of craziness
with LT I just want to know a story that
shows how famous he was whether is it
the Chinese club that you went holy crap
I mean yeah just expounded all of it
because I think it is people want to
hear that stuff not that you have to
tell every detail but were you an
amazement of him too knowing what he was
doing off the field and going dim I know
what he did Friday night and he still
got three sacks on Sunday that's
unbelievable well listen I'm just gonna
tell you and again I'm not here to you
know give out any stories are making the
headlines no we're not here for the
first of all I will say this thank God
that social media was effective that's
all
with that I don't think Lawrence would
be upset if I said that that's one too
is you know he he was a freak yeah
and a good way you know he was just
physically better real yeah then
everybody yeah everybody racial I would
say this
there's I'll give you two quick stories
and then we can move on to something
yeah all right deal and then we'll take
everybody everybody talks about his
shoulder injury in New Orleans but I was
with him all week and I was putting on
his coat and I was putting on his shirt
and the guy could have moved I mean
sweet what was the story since this is
New Orleans 1988 and my dad actually
doesn't play in this game sure as well
Lawrence is banged up Saints are good in
the mid 80s bills and yeah you know a
lot of other good players exactly right
and Lawrence is a sunday night football
game I believe right wreck the defense
dominated the game and he was phenomenal
and what maybe three sad Thank You
bumbles they stay only way he could play
as they strapped him up so I took his
arm and they've strapped it to his chest
to his chest so he couldn't so he had
one arm pay correct and they plenty him
with one already got three sex with one
arm one arm so you so like they would
show the broadcast they like and here's
Lawrence Taylor with he's playing with
one arm they really didn't know that's
not how they talked in the 80s yeah what
the hell was that uh they they they they
they put him in like a like a sling yeah
but it was tied to his thing it's do it
so anyway he and he dominates but the
thing was remarkable to me and I was
saying holy [ __ ] is during the week the
guy couldn't move I mean I really had to
help him well we had an appearance I
remember on Tuesday night of that game
yeah and you're putting his clothes
close up I mean he couldn't he couldn't
move it was incredible sorry so it's
that's that's one story if you want to
look it up on youtube its LT game tape
and it's known as the pain game 1988
verse the Saints you to see and Parcells
talks
about it was like the one of his
crowning moment yeah exactly so I would
say that would be one that I attacked I
remember him
and I'm off the field the other one
would be Friday nights of home games
when his buddies from Williamsburg
Virginia would come to his house and
they would play you know they would play
cards drinking games and they didn't
care who he was he was Lonnie how was
his nickname
it was Lonnie and they would beat him up
not physical okay - all time and twice
they kicked some people out of house I
remember being there one time and he
kicked the guys out of house he made him
go to hotel because it really pissed him
off at one point but he was just like it
was like you hanging around with the gut
your boys when you grew up
I loved those Friday nights yeah you
know I was probably out of half a dozen
of him over the years but it was
terrific it was terrific and the one
thing about Mars hated watching TVs love
watching cartoons I come into the house
he's watching cartoons
always always what is he what's he doing
now
he lives in South Florida Laura's a
survivor I I don't you know I see a mom
you know once a year maybe a charity
event is over about three months ago or
so and always gives me a big hello and
any given Sunday no he was crazy when I
was representing him see that's that's
another thing about Lawrence I want him
to get a theatrical agent and he didn't
do it
but what we did was he was on this
series called first intent was on HBO I
remember it and the star of the show was
on OJ Simpson Wow so when I go out there
to the filming there were some
afternoons that they we would finish at
noon and we wouldn't be back on the
senator for we'd go to the Brentwood
house and those two guys would play
hoops and I was right watch Wow and you
know those are two competitive guys it's
the other thing about Lawrence Taylor he
will not let you he will not let you
when we would play tennis together he
kicked my ass I mean we would play
ping-pong he would I did a little bit
better there yeah you know or cards
his buddies he didn't want to lose I'll
just tell you one of the story and then
we need to move on from arms dealers the
basketball games Lawrence won really
yeah and I had an occasion or two of
holding $10,000 in my hand for a golf
match between Lawrence Taylor and
Michael Jordan yeah right I was gonna
say they played some golf yeah yeah yeah
I did have that a couple times yeah you
were the concerns of Mike in my career
besides Lawrence oh we don't care get
the hell out of here
who won those matches though won the
memoral one is Michael won and how much
shit-talking was between those two there
to North Carolina guys going at it it
was a little bit like are you
uncomfortable in those situations when
you're there cuz but you're you're like
taking it all in but you're also
invested in one of the guys and you're
holding them but it gets serious of
those two like some sky I was in awe of
Michael Jordan kidding me I'm sitting
there you know a little guy from Bayonne
New Jersey you know sitting there I'm
holding money with Lawrence Taylor and
Jordan yeah I was and I mean you know
you're at these Friday night parties
with lt's friends and they're giving him
a hard time yeah Michael Jordan's there
and you're just like how is driving a
golf cart yeah how are they reacting to
you is Jordan talking to you yeah of
course we're all talking crapping on
Steve at that point knocking crap no no
nope oh it only got heated when Omar's I
don't take checks I don't take check to
that guy that got heated it got really
heated and Lawrence is like oh yeah what
the hell I had it make I had a make I
had to go to Western Union transfer oh
that's amazing
that's amazing that's the other news
stories yeah well he's an amazing sports
fan yeah this is one of the thing I want
to talk about me and forget basketball
the loyal friend he is he goes through
the UGA Horniman
yeah goes the NCAA tournament every year
with a group of buddies they pick a city
out they do a weekend there his thing is
though and what we
talk about a lot as friends as the Yanks
we love the Yankees he's very you for
being his outlet for this he's been 40
years he's great 44:44 straight opening
days at Yankee Stadium that's what kind
of Yankee fan he's the kind of guy that
you're like where are you and he's like
I'm in South Africa but I'm coming home
to go to the Yankees opener and then I'm
gonna go back and I'm like what I've
been to three Final Fours at night and
Yankee openers during the day Wow
flying back and forth what is it about
the Yankee opener that you have to be
there for other than the extradition guy
you can ask a lot of my friends and
family learn more about traditions yeah
and and this is one of them it started
and the ironic thing is the Yankee 44
home opening streak started at Shea
Stadium because the Yankee Stadium was
on the construction in 1975 no babies
don't come out 1 years old
the story they tell about you all the
time they love it all right keep telling
your Yankee thing you know so yeah
Yankees growing up you know growing up
and like I said Bayonne New Jersey it
was all about idols back then so you
know I um back then Mickey was at the
Mickey Mantle was at the end of his
career so I latched on to the Yankees
Joe Willie was in his career and I am
this will be my Jets fan authorities
mailer he's a Jets fan 39 years jet
season ticket holder and Ben have been
to 39 straight jet home openers so on
the 39th will be on September 19th
September 16th so you might be the jinx
no I was I was alluding to your speech
one of my favorite things the Superbowl
16w you guys have your parties and you
always love to give a speech and I like
it because you give good speeches but
you had a moment the last speech I
thought it was great because I bought 50
San Francisco rights this is the last
this year
go this year yeah you missed out good
party worried my clients go yeah I
walked I walked in and and roster looked
at me and goes oh who brought you here
but was it number 25 was it there was
Steve goes he goes we're celebrate I
can't do anything goes we're celebrating
a 25th anniversary but as my friend
Frankie voodo told me you don't come out
the womb at 1 years old so technically
this is 24 so we're gonna have another
25th year anniversary next year that's
right it comes to 25th year anniversary
and it's gonna be big we'll be there do
you look at the Super Bowl locations
like do you look at the Final Four like
have you done all that legwork yeah we
don't go to Final Four we always go to
the first round that's the best because
lot for lots of reasons butter cities
yeah back in the day when I wasn't in
the industry I've been going to the last
twenty six or seven years with two of my
high school buddies yeah and what we do
is as soon as we get in our seats for
the Thursday first game we'd like to go
Thursday Saturday we then look at the
program when we pick our site for next
year Wow so we will be going to Hartford
this year we're gonna stay local okay
one friend lives in st. Louis in other
words in DC so it's not local for them
so so well we have traditions best
Italian restaurant that we can find for
for Wednesday night nice Thursday we go
to the games we we fly a box of Zabar's
in for all day of eating on on Friday
and you know that we do not live we do
not leave the room because we're hoop
fanatics and we like to watch all the
games Friday night we have a steak house
deliver their steaks to the to our room
we all flop we all we all must be a mess
oh wow it's my suite by the way we also
each of us fly in two bottles of wine
and depending on what year there'll be a
third so there's at least seven bottles
of wine it and there's a tradition that
yet had to be 95 rated which is a pretty
high
we waited wine right one Italian one
Napa so that we can have a week's get
purple like and and then by Saturday
we're just kind of like it's enough
already one year we went to Omaha would
you go out for the steaks that year we
went out there's not Italian and a lot
is that we went out to Italian
restaurant okay all the V garden okay
he's incredible
and we went out for the Italian
restaurant we got back in our hotel
Wednesday the hotel was connected to the
arena the next time we had fresh air was
Sunday morning when we went to them we
never left the hotel and we never left
that I'm worried that like before you
leave the house every day you're like I
got a touch I got to touch the door now
but I got touched the floor is tradition
the OCD thing worried well I mean if
we're really judge so this is I mean
this is Arles right here if anybody
remembers Arles or Maitre D' I mean this
is Johnny hate when people say oh you
even knew he's Johnny agent though and
can you show everybody your flip your
flip phone
bring out your phone this is this guy I
mean how he long Cris Collinsworth phil
simms Ron darling eyes and LG and it
broke a month or two ago and he went and
got another one like most people would
go okay I guess I'll get the lobster
okay and that's not right six that's not
that's not right no one I have three in
the drawer so I don't have to go by them
oh you don't okay you haven't saved up
yes because what happened is at one
point unless you activate unless you you
have to activate them yeah you can't
just buy him anymore right so when I
knew that they would switch and I just
just got the three in the corner just in
case now they changed the rule see if
you wait long enough this will never get
last time I bought it because of the
kind of package that I'm on it cost me
99 cents what for the phone yeah Wow
but he doesn't get like my middle finger
emojis I sent to him it was a box very
good
I know you might have a grandma okay
it's unreal
wait what is the advantage of a flip
phone very simple
his daughter is laughing about the off
the edge of the room here very simple I
like to control my own destiny so a foot
phone will let me be connected when I
want to be so if I knew if I had text
and I can get a I mean text on it if I
can get emails I'd be on this all day
long I don't want to be that connected
to life I wanted more connected when I
want to be so I carry an iPad when I
wanted to be connected and when I don't
here you go I've heard about I have to
ask you one thing crystal yes is there
one time that you haven't been able to
get in touch no never not one time he is
hey listen you cannot there is no way
that you can have clients like how I
longed for 25 years Chris Sims for
Christmas Phil so Phil Simms for 20
years how he longed for 25 years Chris
Collinsworth for 18 years you just can't
do it unless you know you you you are
reliable and being able to get reached
how do you do it that's I really I don't
think I've ever I don't I am really
amazed because I get sick of my phone or
emails whatever it is dealing with the
personalities presidents of certain you
know corporations dealing with I just
I'm amazed at how your head doesn't pop
off at times um you know the daughter of
35 years so I've kind of gotten the
waiter works for me which is very easy I
mean my father was a dry cleaner for
40-something years a very successful one
by the way in Manhattan it's all about
customer service and like I try to get
something done around my house I called
plumber they don't get back to you or
they come like a week late yeah saying
how the hell they got their business I
don't know I would never have to have my
business that so my thing was always
always reach out always talk talk always
try to be connected and knock on wood
for the guys that I've had that long you
know I represented him for 25 years
they're part of my family I've been when
their kids got born when the kids got
married when my kids got born you know
at unfortunately funerals and you know
good times bad times we're together
and you know that that that leads to at
this point of my career trust and it's
all about trust I'm you know I'm not
saying I'm the greatest at what I do but
at least my clients know that I have
their best friend's interest and to me
that's the most important thing that
they can rely on me that they could
trust me again they might disagree which
is fine and you know truthfully I like a
disagreement everyone so Wow because it
keeps me on my toes why should you do
this or why shouldn't we do why
shouldn't we do try to go a little bit
longer around the contract versus
shorter you know my guys are getting a
little bit older some of the guys I
represent so you know who knows what's
gonna happen on the other hand young
guys like Christopher you know you want
to keep your opportunities open welcome
you know we never we never had we never
had bleacher report you know bleach
report wasn't around six or seven years
ago and look at it now I thought he was
gonna launch you into an airport
accountability rant right there I
thought that was gonna be really good
like you're a little plumber thing he
was walking through an airport being
like do none of you take your job
seriously yes about Christopher
can we talk about mr. perfect go ahead
what do you want to talk about with me
yeah we're doing to go let's go lotta
you versus him a lot of memorable a lot
of moments with Christopher over the
years yes yeah and like you know at the
beginning when he was coming out of
school sure you know remember being what
I meant the at the east-west Shrine game
yeah senior ball senior ball yeah you
know trying to help him through the
process you know and he gave me that day
he gave me a Texas sweatshirt he says I
want you to have this and I still have
it and wear it to this day it's a
meaningful thing for me remembers you
know not only Christopher but you know I
was kind of part of his family then
right yeah you know it was like when how
he asked me to represent Chris law right
you know I mean you take that you know I
don't take that lightly you know it's
one thing about representing them but if
you trot if they trust you with their
children yeah that's really uh I
I actually went through a phase early in
my career now I was young and dumb where
I was like he was so close to me I was a
little uncomfortable almost with the
fact that he was representing me I was
like I'm 20 to 20 and I'm like I I might
say things to him he might tell my dad I
got a little weird with it for a little
while so I broke ties with them for a
few years and then I realized that was
stupid and then trust is way more
important that was that was later on and
you know and truthfully when we when we
had that conversation about you know
afterwards he called me for some advice
and yes I said Chris I just want let you
know I had no problem with you I didn't
understand it maybe we could talked
about a little bit more yeah but I've
been around it long enough to know that
that was the reason it wasn't really
about me personally it was more of his
thing than my thing I knew you know
first of all as I probably told him that
you know I'm still gonna pay the
mortgage if you're a client or not right
right but I have to tell you that you
know if you want somebody who really
cares about yet yeah and not just about
you know the fee you're gonna make then
I'm here and if you want to reconnect
I'm cool let's do it
see how worried he was gonna tell Phil
on you yeah it just he was so close to
me I was almost felt like it was
invasive like I was like I don't know
you know I wasn't the perfect young
citizen at that point either but it was
just all of it I just felt like oh I'm
hearing from my agent and then I'm also
what I hired you give you a credit when
you weren't perfect young young lad or
maybe what you worried that you fest up
to it I usually you would calm and you
would say hey yeah I [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
right you know yes all right so all
right yeah you know and I did too when I
was young so let's see how we can make
this work so that's one memorable thing
or you know gave him suggestions on who
should do his contract and we meet we
met with them and it went through that
process yeah you know a horrible not a
horrible not a great memory it was the
night of his house during the draft it
was it was a rough rough day that was a
rough day and I was there and
I was there to the end and I have to
tell you I went home and I was I was
really bummed I was really bummed was
back but not for not same day well was
the first three first three was a first
time I seen anyway that was one we
talked about we talked about you know
the being the big 12 game yeah and then
you really bring up the positive well
I'm gonna get I mean the playoff game
and walk against Washington was you know
just incredible yeah it was like it was
unbelievable yeah it was unbelievable
and that guy should have caught the ball
you don't Shepard so okay and then
talking about you know crisis I had to
tell his father about the spleen right
oh he didn't realize because dad was on
the air when he kids Berg yeah and he
was on the way and I got the call from
[Music]
know that the team called me because
they had my I was dealing what I was
doing the promotional guys all the time
they called me and told me and I had to
get Phil on the phone and he had just
clicked something somebody had just told
them or whatever so then we had to go
into that mode about you know what that
meant and we all didn't know what that
meant and you know that was just that
was a scary time yeah and then I was
with Chris a lotta thordan door in the
rehab and I could see he was really
frustrated it wasn't going well yeah he
couldn't get it back and we were trying
to you know the different doctors and
going up to Canada to do that I would
see him train and you at the police you
know I took out of creases and but this
is where when you talked about being
close his father needed something to his
father needed a conversation about this
feels very close to the vest guy and he
doesn't open up but I remember one time
I went over the house he asked me come
up and he was you know he was pretty
shaken up about it you know he was not
only concerned about his career but you
know he was concerned about you know
your health and how you
are gonna handle this because I think
push comes to shove he probably didn't
he probably didn't know that if you ever
gonna get back to where you were right
right so then he was saying this is my
son what you know what's next for him
right you know and then you know Chris
bounced around and I remember you know
the Denver thing you call in and say
what do you think and there's a lot of
money he never played it's a lot of
money because you know I think it was
Condon I'm saying I couldn't believe I
thought maybe my flip phone wasn't
working
maybe he emojis are all right without
the Denver and I was just starting to
feel good and they wanted a good work he
wanted me to go out and work out over
that and I was like damn okay I'm ready
to go to the workout but the problem was
I'm not joking you as 50 mile-per-hour
winds outside and I was like man I could
be Brett Favre right now and they're not
they might not know and I was so juiced
up but they brought me out there and I
just remember just I was just like
everyone through the rent the wind and I
threw about 20 balls and they looked at
me they're like okay we're gonna go get
a deal done and that was it I remember
you working out for the pro scouts at
Giants they yeah right remember cuz you
had to find a place to do it yeah you'll
have to be somewhere within 20 miles of
where you grew up I didn't want to go
back to Texas and do my pro day there I
wanted to train up here in Jersey be in
my element right you know have mom's
cooking all that kind of stuff
sleeping your man yes so then you have
to find a place to have your workout
somewhere close to your home and Phil
decides he doesn't want to go so I yell
never know you know Phil was sensitive
to it he was no I you know Phil was
don't forget he was he was not it he was
not only you know the quarterback he was
he was you know the number one analyst
so he was seeing a lot of these people
every week so he wanted to he thought
being there would have been a negative
so we I think looking back at some of
that maybe he might have changed his
mind
yeah you know we went through the same
thing with Matt right yeah that's what I
get why Phil doesn't we want Phil in the
Hall of Fame really bad at least I do
Chris tries to stay out of it and be
like really diplomatic which is adorable
but we I want to start pressuring some
local media
guys and even if it's not just playing
days the 25 years at 25 years from CBS
19 B 20 about 20 years plus inside the
NFL and all that I mean I I wanted to
happen sooner than later and I know that
you probably feel that way too so I
guess I'm asking to join can you join
the movement
you know like David Baker you have the
Super Bowl party David Baker knew some
more and then can't be involved you
can't nope I've gotten the the Phil told
you to shut the hell up about it
after the fifth time I brought it I'm
sure really oh so you were you kind of
lunch master if we could go for a little
campaign a couple years yeah maybe maybe
six seven years ago yeah said absolutely
not he's not he's not gonna let it
happen but I believe you could surprise
see the problem that we're gonna have
would fill getting in the Hall of Fame
and the same thing truthfully with
boomer boomers got some really good
numbers yeah right it's just because the
day and age of the numbers that are
gonna come right these guys are gonna
put unbelievable numbers up you're gonna
get a lot more first-timers in the whole
thing than ever before which I believe
is a little bit of a joke yes all right
because of the numbers that they were
able to put up while they were playing
they're gonna look at Phil's numbers and
boomers numbers and Kenny Anderson's
number yeah they're gonna say well we
gotta put this guy any true for you know
40,000 whatever it's gonna be so yeah so
that's gonna be a little bit but like
they don't they the one thing unless and
everybody says okay the second Super
Bowl you got hurt yeah okay but you know
he he does get some sort of credit they
were 11 and yeah they were 11 and two or
something when I got Carson Wentz this
year but that's okay so you finally were
able to say it hey felt good I haven't
been able to say this in 69 so you baby
okay I say start Bridgewater since you
asked but Phil you also got a
everybody talks about that but they
don't talk about the system that he
played in his best wide receiver ever
was Lionel Mariel nothing it's Lionel
yeah I mean Bavaro was obviously a
really good player right but you only
can do so much from from inside and and
I was looking at some stat at once I
said in this tattoo to boomer and Phil I
can't remember exactly about how many
touchdown passes within the 5-yard line
that each of them had compared to Brett
Farr oh they probably don't even it
doesn't exactly Favre had more I think I
remember more in two years and Phil I
was old because if you remember he would
throw a bootleg he they throw to Bubba
Frank's in the back and they would throw
T's yeah you know marcha for they would
throw one or two yards I don't know if
it was just a pad Brett's numbers or not
but you know Parcells was running the
ball he was coming in a Moute core and
he was given it to Joe Mars he was given
OJ Anderson he was gonna run the ball
there is no way that a coach Parcells is
throwing it from the two years it's such
a huge part of today's games well yeah
it is it did become a little bit padding
stats right just because at the end of
the day I do think like certain offenses
they're very aware of their quarterbacks
numbers yeah but if you let me look good
if you talk to guys in the Aero a Phil
though Dom that's what I'm saying that's
something else you know I represented
Troy Aikman and Steve Young early early
in my career they had both won a Super
Bowl at the time I was representing them
and they would always talk about Phil
and how tough he was and how he threw
that ball and how tough it was throwing
a ball at Giants Stadium yeah that's
another thing I know you throw it you
throw in Dallas you know the roof is
covered him yes I Stevie okay when he
played a candlestick yeah there was
blowing yeah but you know he also had
Jerry Rice right you know so the
combination but when your peers talk
about it that's a whole different thing
and you know those are you know just two
guys who I represented that really
talked you know I feel like that's why
he kind of needs like Belichick and
Parcells
to come out and like explain the history
and I feel like Belichick is that kind
of guy where if he says we really need
to look back and appreciate what
happened in the style of the game and
the air the atmosphere which he played
and how he was the only quarterback that
maybe could have played for Parcells and
taken that beating I have an idea for
you as part of your yes you're taking
this role right what is it
the phil simms getting involved yes I
want you to go to a press conference
that New England's Belichick and I want
just happens nowhere class just ask him
by the way I think that do you think
that Phil ship should be that would
actually be a really good skit for the
show that's it bingo
they should go up okay I say yep so my
thing that we get your driver to drive
them up there Jason I want to do one
last thing before you go because you've
given us plenty of your time and I
appreciate it
I want you to put on back your player
representation hats Sims Christopher is
going to be Odell Beckham I am going to
be the Giants organization and I'd like
you to be representing Odell and so if
you could just you know pitch him to me
and how you would do it if you're
representing Odell trying to get this
deal done before the season all right
first of all before I play your little
you know it's a game yeah it's a good
game or you know Justin air and prompt
to you know I want to feel I would
prefer to be Gettleman because I don't
think he should get I I I think the
Giants have done the right thing so far
all right right so all right you could
be gentlemen that's even better
okay all right so then we're both gonna
be Odell's agents okay perfect they're
gentlemen okay where are the agents okay
mister gentlemen thank you so much for
having us here okay
raagh Molly's we honestly wish it was a
few weeks sooner frankly we kind of
think it should have been a year ago our
client mr. Odell Beckham jr. in your
minds is the best wide receiver had ever
played the game possibly talent line
well I mean hey listen it's hard to
argue that guys like Julio Jones and
some of these other receivers that are
being paid more than Odell Beckham jr.
as good or better than him at this point
of his career he's in the prime right
now he's in the prime look at your
quarterback stats your quarterback not
very good unless Odell's on the field
with them so you want to win one more
two
more do right by the guy who's been a
professional this all season in fact
he's been such a professional he's been
here he's performed in 11 on 11s he's
practiced with a team he's been sterling
off the field except for that one video
that mr. Kent I'm gonna I'm pretty sure
we're tracing it back to the New York
Giants organization how that got out
there 10 years ago but that's for a
different meeting get out of my [ __ ]
office that's how you'd start that right
there if you tell me that it came from
my organization well first of all let me
tell you we also believe he is a great
great talent so let's start there and we
do want him part of this organization
however there is a system in place ok
and the system is very simple
ok he signed his first contract he had
no complaints about it ok he has
performed well but he'd have to agree
he's been somewhat injured especially
last year the year now a year later
without really performing for almost two
years that you want your money which
were we're willing to give you more
money ok however just not forget we
don't need to do this ok we don't need
to do this your Players Association have
signed an agreement that is in place
right now that says we really don't have
to pay him and we don't have to pay him
for the next we have to pay him but we
can franchise him for the next two years
we can control him for the next hole no
you're gonna throw these two franchises
at me with a guy of Odell's character
that you know is the face of the
franchise and maybe the entire but hold
it the money that we're talking about on
the franchise tag is not chump change my
client needs security long terms longer
okay we are out here throwing one year
wheels we like he's some jamoke then
let's no no I never said that don't put
words in my mouth okay so what I would
do is tell you this we will look for an
insurance policy that will that we both
can agree on that will take care of him
but at the same time we are willing to
negotiate okay but do you pass my stress
my late mother says you can't be a Haza
okay all right
so if I offer you sixteen and a half
million dollars yeah and you want 18
million we want to pay you sixteen
million
it's your choice not to sign it okay and
what he's making now is 8 million more
then we're gonna rip it up so if you
want to take a chance for an extra
million or two to squeeze us here
without the guy playing hmm okay we can
say no and you're gonna cost your client
8 million this year because we're gonna
pay him 8.5 million what his contract
calls for all right now flip and by the
way we think he has been a good citizen
okay and John Merrow who I just talked
to a couple minutes ago before you came
in I just wanted to touch base with him
yeah yeah and he said tell these folks
that we are we love the guy and he has
lived up to it so now let's try to get a
deal done that works for both of us and
not just you guys I see what you did
there so you started off very
complementary in the middle the
insurance policy kind of took care of
the whole long good but flip it if you
were then representing Adele and you
heard that what is the what is the
Odelle line back to that you know I
really don't care about anybody else I'm
talking about my guy yeah you know my
guy has performed right my guy has made
your quarterback look maybe not as old
as he looks okay right and granted he
has been hurt but this is a vicious
sport yeah okay people get hurt hmm okay
let's maybe you shouldn't play them in
that preseason game that you played them
in that's right like at that point yeah
so why don't we just not you know why
don't we do this why don't we be
creative
okay now creative is very easy you're a
deal making that a deal breaker
okay he's heard that at least 20 times
okay so why don't we just go scream why
don't we do this okay okay you want it's
all about guaranteed money or is it
about the overall money so there's two
different things okay so let's make sure
that we're on the same page there that's
one two is we also have a salary cap
that we have two all right
that means upfront money that's means
signing bonus alright so let's work out
something there that can that we both
can live with it you get you guaranteed
money but the bottom line is if you're
gonna want to be the highest-paid player
we're concerned about that
oh you close your back to the Giants I
didn't who you representing no no no I'm
okay but Odell Beckham yes okay there's
another guy who played in this town
Amani Toomer another guy will play in
this town Plaxico Burress nothing I
played this county who were green that
he kept saying Johnson he wanted to be
the highest-paid player but then when
somebody else becomes the highest-paid
player he's not gonna add or two years
later so I will tell you one thing I'm
gonna go back to gentlemen okay get on
ok if we give you your money
you're gonna sign a piece of paper that
you're not gonna come knock on our door
for five years hmm
I'll give you the money I'll give it to
you now I don't want to hear it again
like a whole joke okay that's it do not
come in because Darrelle Revis came in
all those times yes when he was under
contract
he made us look like the bad guys but he
was the one who really was the fahza and
not us right house well don't be a Haza
I was great cause oh yeah I was like
lehayim
almost I told you Jewish yeah he's like
he's like I'm two percent Jewish their
whole family's translucent you know yeah
I was good
it's got to be 10% he don't he I don't
know he's the whitest person as well
this is the guy he's got a black
girlfriend and he tries to he tries to
prove that he doesn't need sunscreen he
goes on a vacation to her Anguilla and
he goes and just gets absolutely
tortured like severe to the point where
Simms came out to me the next day and
was like
I'm really concerned about like his
shoulders were as red as your shirt I
mean they were just layers of skin but
now I have really smooth shoulders
because it's all brand new well I've
learned a long time ago Oh would you
like you mind your own business mind
your own business let people live their
lives because you really don't know
what's really behind the closed door
yeah I know but some you know I know
your own time but you know I bet you
don't know everything about no I don't
he I tell him everything about me he
keeps secrets we don't have an equal
relationship how did this turn on
minutes great person huh see you're a
great person nobody said you weren't so
where'd you come from
a little like guilt play there my
daughter's a lot of fun we've been
talking about you so it's good everybody
gets to hear your voice finally as I
told my wife they must be you know light
on guest this week no we're kind of a
big deal to things we knew that you're
gonna have the stories and we knew that
your voice for the audio was gonna be
perfect yes and you know early on in my
career people asked me if I was in the
radio business mmm I could see that yeah
you know yeah we hear that music that
means we're done we're done Steve you're
the man dude all right appreciate you
being out now we refer Thank You Steven
always a pleasure always I'm just gonna
let 16 W 16 W in the house for Simms
peace out homey fur fur federic ver
Rosner Steven Christopher and for the
lef koe man have a great weekend
everybody love you so much talk to you
soon and holla holla holla holla holla
holla holla peace